I got like this movie was a bit of a
nostalgia bomb scary stories to tell in
the dark so scary stories is an
adaptation of the young adult book scary
stories I say young adult before a young
adult novel meant you know teen romance
scary stories was a book trilogy unless
they made a fourth one that I wasn't
aware of there are three of them and now
they've adapted it into a film and
hadley play it out it's not like the
twilight zone movie there's like a
series of unlinked short story it's not
scary stories this group of youth find
this book and this book has scary
stories as book starts writing stories
out and the stories play themselves out
and start terrorizing them and the
stories that are happening are familiar
scary stories from the book that we know
so it's kind of like goosebumps for
older kids and actually dug it granted
it might be because I recognized the
stories like I remember a couple of the
stories from my youth but as the movie
was going on and these stories start
happening like oh my god and remember
that I really remembered the red dot on
the face and then yeah but that's half
the fun is seeing which one of the scary
stories from the book they're actually
putting in this movie but I actually
enjoyed the group of kids like the main
protagonist edit charming quality about
them they're not bad actors actually did
well in this movie and as much as I
wasn't expecting to have a moment or two
of like yeah that it's actually pretty
great we're a couple of moments that did
that that thing down the hallway looks
like pillsbury from hell I don't know
props with that that was actually a
creepy moment actually had a gross-out
gags moment else I don't do that I don't
really know the age demographic this
movie's trying to play to begin the
early 90s when book day happened you
remember book day if you don't unless
because Amazon exists what for we older
kids book day and we ordered scary
stories and it was the coolest book ever
because we didn't want that tame stuff
anymore we want something a little more
hardcore so this book played to that
demographic but now times have changed
now kids are like the thing that's weak
that's tame right there the scary
stories book came out before parents
even had the opportunity to be outraged
over Mortal Kombat that's how old it was
azar the demographic this movie was made
for have played Mortal Kombat 11 those
movie might be a bit tame for the
audience it's going for so maybe they
could have just made this rated R maybe
they're hoping the parents can take
their teenagers to it and be like this
is what I grew up on Timmy keep you like
this is weak dad you do realize I saw
them cut the young Greyjoy's dick off
what's this to me doesn't mean the movie
doesn't push the boundaries where it can
it is a pg-13 horror movie and it's not
as cheesy as a lot of the other pg-13
horror movies that are actually out
there cause in the end scary stories to
tell in the dark I really enjoyed it you
feel like they saw it and they were like
eh that losers Club thing we're gonna go
ahead and do that it's like it's the
gobots version of it not that having a
group of likeable protagonists youth
there's anything new in horror movies
not like it's a new concept but it's
like Hollywood got it after it I feel
like the movies trying to ride a line
but you know for the most part it rides
the lines well elementary school kids
they were in on the book so it tries to
bring that demographic into it all the
while trying to keep the parents
entertained all the while trying to keep
the kids entertained but the scares and
the gore but not making it too hardcore
but sometimes lending itself to getting
a little more hardcore but never being
rated our hardcore always maintaining
pg-13 all in all I walked away having a
good time I'll say it was a good time no
alcohol required some of the CGI looks
pretty fake CGI but I didn't expect it
to look real at no point was I like
scary stories it's gonna be a movie the
CGI is totally gonna look like it's a
big-budget Disney film I gotta know what
I'm in for us and you should know what
you're in for
all right so scary stories to tell in
the dark have you seen it what did you
think about it or did you read the books
and if you did what's your favorite
story from them whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]